Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg today
finally speaking out admitting mistakes
and vowing to correct them in a
statement saying we have a
responsibility to protect your data and
if we can't then we don't deserve to
serve you Sheryl Sandberg adding we know
this was a major violation of people's
trust and I deeply regret we didn't do
enough to deal with it for days Facebook
has been pummeled in the market hammered
in the press and in Washington's
crosshairs first thing that has to
happen is Facebook needs to come in and
talk to Congress
Facebook's challenged how to balance
user privacy with a business model that
exploits their personal data for profits
if people don't trust that they are safe
they would stop using it and their
entire business model starts to go away
Facebook's undoing began years ago when
it gave a British app developer access
to its database of users the situation
shows you know 270,000 people took a
survey 50 million people were impacted
and their data was accessed Facebook
claims it did not know the data was for
sale and unbeknownst to users and their
friends and family survey answers were
sold to Cambridge analytic ah the
company co-founded by former Trump
campaign adviser Steve Bannon GOP
fundraiser Robert Mercer and Alexander
Nicks who ran the company until he was
suspended this week after an undercover
TV report appeared to show him bragging
about corrupting public officials with
money and hookers we really need to do a
data audit to find out whether this
personal information was acquired by
Cambridge analytics
whether or not Facebook took appropriate
measures when they found that there may
have been a breach federal records show
the Trump campaign paid Cambridge almost
six million dollars in 2016 but campaign
officials say they only used RNC data
not Facebook data to target voters yet
both companies are under scrutiny for
their use or misuse of personal
information check this box that is
buried in the minutiae of a you know 16
page document Zuckerberg said in the
future Facebook would restrict app
developers access to only a user's name
photo and email and would remove their
access altogether if you haven't used
the app in the last three months but
sources say it's unlikely to stop
Congress from calling Zuckerberg
justify